Taylor Swift just dropped another hint
about her upcoming album and it is a
doozy get this guy's the singer who has
spent years refraining from discussing
politics publicly is now saying that
there will be some quote political
undertones in her new music in a new
interview with German outlet RTL Taylor
explained quote I definitely think there
are political undertones in the new
music I made I'm not planning to stop
encouraging young people to vote and to
try to get them to talk about what's
going on in our country I think that's
one of the most important things I could
do yes Taylor finally but to be fair
Taylor did open up about politics in
October 2018 just before the midterm
election endorsing two candidates Phil
Bredesen / Senate and Jim Cooper for
House of Representatives
she explained quote as much as I have in
the past and would like to continue
voting for women in office I cannot
support Marsha Blackburn Taylor went on
to explain that Blackburn's voting
record terrified her sharing a laundry
list of reasons including that Blackburn
voted against equal pay for women
against an act that would protect women
from domestic violence and that
Blackburn is against LGBTQ rights as
Taylor put it these are not my Tennessee
values after Taylor went public vote at
or got a wave of new voter registrations
in fact the director of communications
told BuzzFeed they were up 65,000
registrations in the 24 hours following
Swift's post but for now we're just
gonna have to wait to find out what
these political undertones are when
Taylor's album drops whenever that is
until then I'll just be here playing me
on repeat
you'll never find another like me
[Music]
Taylor dropped me the first single off
her seventh studio album in April and
confirmed that her new album title is
revealed in the music video and she
dropped an even bigger hint in a recent
interview with the independent when
asked how many title clues are in the me
music video her response I think you see
it once and you hear it twice Taylor
fans quickly went to work doing what
Taylor fans do and they seem to think
the title the new album is a lover since
it shows up twice in the lyrics and you
see it in the video right there I cannot
wait for Taylor's new album I think this
is gonna be the best one yet and of
course we'll be here to talk all things
Taylor Swift with you so be sure to keep
it locked on UT until next time I'm
Haley Stephens bye for now
[Music]